[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sport dem sport
podcast des österreichischen bundesheers
mein name ist andreas so näher ich bin
selbst heeressportler und heute zu gast
im sport verena ebert bahn unter straßen
rad fahren herzlich willkommen
irena wie geht's dir gut wir machen
trainingslager imperator sicher stadion
in wien und das training läuft
eigentlich super die vorbereitungen
laufen für die nächste saison uns ja es
passt eigentlich was hast du denn alles
vorgenommen
für die nächste es ist und wie schaut
das bei dir aus bei uns ist es so dass
das ganze system ein bisschen umgestellt
wurde das heißt die weltcups sind jetzt
auf nations cups umbenannt worden
und sie finden jetzt statt wie bisher im
winter jetzt im sommer statt das heißt
april geht schon los mit dem ersten
nations cups in großbritannien in
kolumbien und in hongkong und da werden
natürlich wieder versuchen aufs podium
zu fahren und im juni gibt's dann die
europameisterschaft und auch bei der ist
für mich nach wie vor das ziel einfach
mal bei einer em und wm eine medaille zu
holen
das habe ich bisher noch nicht noch
nicht aber du bist ja noch jung und hat
es dann noch einige möglichkeiten vor
die olympia hat ja ganz knapp nicht
geklappt das war ein großer und ein
großes ziel die ich auf der bahn für
olympia zu qualifizieren was hat denn
genau gefehlt wie läuft das dadurch ab
mit der qualifikation hier bei uns kann
man sagen dass die quali eigentlich
schon zwei jahre vor olympia beginnt und
meiner meinung nach sind große nationen
klar im vorteil weil es gibt 21 plätze
weltweit und davon sind eigentlich nur
sechs plätze für einzelkämpfer im vorher
gesehen dass die anderen nationen können
sich über disziplinen qualifizieren die
ich einfach nicht ausführen kann weil
ich der einzige bin die in österreich
internationale rennen und fährt
dementsprechend sind die sechs plätze
sehr sehr hart umkämpft und es ist
einfach ganz schwierig dass man
monatelang durch die welt reist und im
winter eigentlich sechs weltcups fahren
muss oder eine vielleicht in australien
ist nix dann in hongkong und ein
externer europa und das innerhalb von
drei wochen
und als einzel fahrerin muss man
eigentlich dann fast alles
waren wohin gegen große nationen beim
weltcup die eine person hin schicken und
die nächste kommt dann eigentlich
relativ frisch die andere fahrerin zum
nächsten weltcup
dementsprechend geht dann irgendwann die
luft aus und das war eigentlich soll das
hauptproblem
das heißt die animationen können diese
plätze gemeinsam im team sozusagen für
die nation erfahren und entscheiden dann
wer hinfährt und du willst dass das
alles alleine machen in verschiedensten
disziplinen aber ich nehme mal an dass
der traum olympia jetzt deswegen oder
wegen dem system für dich ja noch nicht
erledigt ist
wie gehst du denn für paris das ziel der
qualifikation an
ja es ist definitiv noch nicht fertig
ich sage mal 20 24 kann kommen und für
mich ist das gute das jetzt die qual
verändert hat das heißt wir müssen sich
jetzt nichts wir müssen uns nicht für
die weltcups extra qualifizieren das
heißt bisher war es so dass wir einen
ganzen sommer rumgereist sind dass wir
im winter überhaupt einen weltcup
starten können und jetzt ist es so wenn
du nur gewisse anzahl von punkten hast
kannst du zumindest direkt bei den
weltcups einsteigen
und da gibt es dann quali vorläufe
dementsprechend haben kleinere nationen
jetzt endlich mal ein vorteil
und wenn sie das so beibehalten bis
paris dann würde ich mal sagen ist
stehen die chancen viel besser als für
tokio das wünschen uns natürlich und
hoffen wir natürlich dass angesprochen
dass man da verschiedene disziplinen
fahren muss welche disziplinen auf der
bahn liegen dir dann am besten das ist
eine spezialität
also meine liebsten ländern sind
eigentlich das punkte ländern unter
scratch wobei die einzige olympische
disziplin das omnium ist und zwar das
ist ein mehrkampf ein vierkampf
bestehend aus den punkterängen scratch
ausscheidungsrennen uns temperieren
und ja es geht einfach auf der bahn sehr
viel um taktisches können und technisch
gutes waren dementsprechend ist es mehr
offen würde man sagen es auf den straßen
erinnern wo oft kilometerlang oder
stundenlang dahin gefahren werden und
was nur wenige attacken gibt das ist
ganz anders auf der bahn da wird
wirklich ständig attackiert und es geht
wirklich schnell zur sache ist etwas was
dich fasziniert am band radsport und ja
definitiv das ist
eigentlich das was man meisten reizt
zeuge x die hohen geschwindigkeiten die
wir da fahren wir haben bei 15 bis 20 km
rennen teilweise schon
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeiten über 52
km h und bei den männern jetzt noch
schneller zur sache also das ist glaube
ich schon ganz beeindruckend
kannst du diese kinder vielleicht auch
kurz erklären also was ist wenn man
punkte fahren macht vielleicht noch aus
der logik sehen aber scratch
einerverfolgung ausscheidungsfahren das
kann sie vielleicht auch noch irgendwie
aber zusammenreimen aber vielleicht
erklärst du ganz kurz was die einzelnen
disziplinen bedeuten ja also ausstellern
ist im grunde ein rennen mit entwertung
wer als erster über die ziellinie fährt
hat gewonnen und das punkterennen und
ist wie der name schon sagt man muss
über den also über den zeitraum hinweg
so viele punkte wie möglich sammeln
das kann man zum einen bei den
wertungssprints machen die alle zehn
minuten stattfinden oder man fährt
sozusagen einmal um die ganze gruppe
das gibt dann gleich 20 punkte dafür
müsste man eigentlich schon vier
wertungen für kleine sprintwertungen
gewinnen um auf diese 20 punkte zu
kommen und das ist dann ja meine taktik
weil ich jetzt nicht die extrem sprint
schneller person bin sondern er dann auf
diese plus runden gehen und somit kommt
man natürlich schneller nach vorne und
ja die einzelverfolgung man startet im
endeffekt gegenüber voneinander gegen
die zeit und auch gegen den
unmittelbaren partner da gibt es oft
quali läufe und am ende steht man im
finale und entweder zeit oder im
idealfall wenn man die andere person
einholt dann hat man sowieso gewonnen
sagen wir mal und das selber gibt es
noch im team das werde team
mannschaftsverfolgung
dann muss meine österreichischen
kollegen gut machen ist das madison
darunter vier olympia qualifiziert da
fand es zu zweit und müssen sie immer
abschlagen sozusagen mit der hand und
temporär das ähnlich wie das
punkterennen nur dass es dabei einfach
jede runde einen punkt gibt nicht nur
jeder zehnte also von außen schaut das
fast immer so aus als würde man nur
im kreis fahren aber es geht um sehr
viel mehr das vor angesprochen dass du
eine einzelkämpferin bist wie kann man
sich das genau vorstellen was bedeutet
das dass du da in österreich als einzige
dame auch international präsent ist im
radsport
ja ich würde mir natürlich hoffen dass
mehr mädels da tätig sind im
bahnradsport und es schaut als zumindest
gut aus dass mehr interesse zeigen
also wir haben die letzten jahre schon
aber mehr bei den österreichischen
meisterschaften die danach teilnehmen
und ja als einzelkämpferinnen würde ich
sagen ist es aber auch schwer weil man
einen kleinen rennen keine hilfe hat
wohingegen bei den großen europa und
weltmeisterschaften ist es komplett egal
weil nur maximal eine fahrerin pro
nation beim rennen teilnehmen darf das
heißt aber eigentlich keinen nachteil im
gegensatz zu den kleinen erinnern wie
oft extrem team mäßig gefahren wird
obwohl es vom internationalen verband
eigentlich gar nicht so erlaubt es warum
glaube so liegt das dass ich meine dass
du jetzt erfolgreich bist über die
gründer werden wir dann auch gleich
reden warum du es geschafft hast aber
woran liegt es dass das so wenige damen
auf der bahn fahren in österreich es
wird zu wenig schmackhaft gemacht
vielleicht es gibt auf der bahn
eigentlich nur dann die möglichkeit geld
zu verdienen wenn man halt von
bundesheer oder von der polizei
unterstützt wird und es jetzt nicht so
wie auf der straße dass man dann große
preisgelder haut im gegenteil man muss
irgendwie scheint es mal überlebt und
dementsprechend bin ich natürlich sehr
dankbar für die unterstützung von
bundesheer
ohne das wäre gar nicht möglich und auf
der straße ist es dann schon so wenn man
wirklich gute erfolge gehabt dann kann
man schon ein ganz gutes gehalt bekommen
wobei wir noch lange nicht da sind wo
die männer sind die da wirklich
teilweise millionen verdienen das ist
leider ist der unterschied von frauen
und männer sport noch immer sehr sehr
groß obwohl wir meiner meinung nach
selbes leisten oder teilweise sogar mehr
was müsste man da ändern also außer
natürlich die entlohnung also dass wir
das brauchen damit man da eine anpassung
erreicht so zwischen damen- und
herrenrad sport zum einen müssen einfach
die medien einsteigen glaube dass mehr
im fernsehen übertragen wird und ganz
einfach dass das besser vermarktet wird
weil es ist es enorm interessant und ich
glaube vor allem der bahnradsport ist
super für zuschauer weil du ständig
alles sie ist in den zuschauertribünen
kriegst du das ganze rennen mit und
kriegst jede attacke mit und nicht so
wie im straßenradsport wo du eigentlich
die fahrer in 23 sekunden vorbei fahren
sie das ist eigentlich sehr sehr
interessante sportart wie ist das bei
dir eigentlich dazu gekommen dass du
jetzt dich entschieden hast radprofi zu
werden oder zu versuchen immer parat
internationale erfolge zu erfahren meine
anfänge aber interessanterweise in einer
ganz anderen sportart gemacht und zwar
im akrobatischen sprüngen
das mögen wir jetzt nicht mehr glauben
ich glaube sie schaut jetzt sogar das
bei mir
und ja mein freundeskreis damals hat mir
irgendwie dazu überzeugt dass ich einen
marathon start und bin direkt bei der
allgemeinen klasse als 15 jähriges mädel
am dritten platz gelandet und ja sie
habe mir dann dazu überredet mehr oder
weniger jahr macht es doch hab dann
einige jahre lang nicht beides gemacht
und ich bin dann in einer sport
gymnasium gegangen und da habe ich mir
schon für eine haupt sportart
entscheiden müssen
mir war dann irgendwie klar neue
herausforderungen und mehr möglichkeiten
habe einfach im märz sport und so hat
sich das dann eigentlich entwickelt und
ich nehme an dass die anfänge ja nicht
einfach sind vor allem ist ein sehr
material intensiver sport wie hast du
das geschafft mit mit den reisen mit mit
einem mit den rädern räder hast du das
wird mich recht auch interessiert ich
habe aktuell
zwei straßen räder ein zeitfahrrad zwei
bahn räder ein mountainbike also es
schon sehr sehr viel sitzung
zusammenkommt immer so war sein glück
gehabt dass das erste fahrrad einfach
meine eltern finanzieren konnten
und danach habe ich immer wieder
sponsoren bekommen der einfach nie
wirklich unterstützt haben und ohne das
wäre gar nicht möglich gewesen
ich bin relativ schnell dann als junior
ins ausland gegangen für straßenrändern
wollte eigentlich bei die sehr gutes
material zur verfügung gestellt bekommen
habe und ich habe dabei war ganz gute
entscheidungen getroffen in jungen
jahren so dass sie eigentlich überhaupt
in der richtung gehen haben können war
das will ich immer klar so ich werde
profi ich schaffe das ich kann das oder
hast du immer auch einen plan b
irgendwie offen gehalten also wollte es
jetzt natürlich in jungen jahren
definitiv probieren 100 prozentig sicher
kann man sich natürlich nie sein im
leistungssport wie langweilt es noch
ausführen kann
dementsprechend soll wenn man immer
versucht irgendwie daneben da was
aufzubauen habe dann halt die matura
gemacht und direkt danach eigentlich
begonnen zu studieren und hab da jetzt
endlich meinen bachelor in
sportwissenschaften in der tasche also
dass einige jahre gedauert länger als
man natürlich als der durchschnitt
student macht aber ja es ist nicht immer
leicht gewesen und sage mal nur ich bin
eigentlich ganz gut von cara unterstützt
waren die man sehr viele also gute guter
china gegeben haben dass sie den sport
mit der ausbildung kombiniert
hast du das gefühl dass jetzt schon von
der sportwissenschaften also vom studium
euro profitiert dass du vielleicht ein
wenig besser verstehe ist dass du da
bessere einblicke hast ist es auch etwas
was dir jetzt schon hilft ja definitiv
also ich bin sehr interessiert in die
ganze materie und sportwissenschaften
ist er so weit gefächertes thema sage
malen da an der uni wien noch mal
wirklich sehr viel gelernt von sport
politik geschichte physiologie anatomie
und physiologie anatomie sehr
interessiert was natürlich an island ist
und daraus trainingsplanung und
zusammenarbeit für mitnehmen können ist
bei euch sehr
trainings intensiv dass das rad training
das er vor gesagt dass du im ausland
sehr viel
mitnehmen konntest welche erfahrungen
hast du da gemacht dich geprägt haben
vor allem glaube die ersten zwei jahre
waren sehr sehr gut weil die junge
fahrerin war und sehr es wirklich
vorbilder bei mir im team gehabt habe
emma pooley zum beispiel die früher
weltmeisterin war eigentlich meine
teamkollegen und war wirklich stolz
darauf und die fahrerinnen waren
eigentlich so ja gewählt wir viele
sachen beizubringen was jetzt technik
und taktik anbelangt und da habe sicher
viel profitiert du hast einen größten
sportlichen erfolg bei den europa
spielen mit der silbermedaille geschafft
die war das damals diesen diesen erfolg
zu schaffen
ja es war für mich einfach wie ein
aufatmen ein ende der durststrecke
sozusagen weil er wirklich schon
jahrelang versucht habe eine
internationale medaille zu erreichen und
es ist oft vierter plätze bei weltcups
und fünfte plätze aber wollen in dem
moment weil ich die medaille klar war da
war wirklich sehr sehr glücklich wie
durchlebt man solche momente wenn man
dann weiß die harte arbeit all das was
man hinein investiert hat vor allem auch
verletzungen die immer wieder
aufgetreten sind wie schaut man da auf
diese momente dann intensiv emotional
zurück ja es im endeffekt ist es dann
all die alles was man durch geht
eigentlich ist alles das wäre in dem
moment wo man dann am polen steht bzw
durch über die ziele in der fährt da
weiß man dass das ist genau das was man
will das ist genau das für das man
jahrelang trainiert hat und es ist schon
ein schönes gefühl wenn man weiß es hat
sich endlich ausgezahlt
ich hab jetzt kurz auch schon eine
verletzung angesprochen du hast dir auch
schon einmal einen lendenwirbel
gebrochen wie es das passiert und wie
hat sich das geprägt ja das war relativ
früh eigentlich in meiner karriere
das war 2012 in einer ganz normalen
trainings ausfahrt hat mir eine
besonnen auto im cup packenden autoritär
aufgemacht und im nächsten moment muss
ich mich erinnern kann die gern boden
bewusstlos war wieder auf und kann aber
von selbst aufstehen habe mich von oben
und unten eingeprägt haben wir auch okay
nicht mal auf schürfungen oder das ok
team rücken oder bisschen weh aber wenn
man stürzt dann kann man immer alles
also haben jetzt gar nicht viel dabei
gedacht und wollte eigentlich wieder mit
meinem training fortfahren weil haben 23
intervalle zu machen also dem uns jetzt
schon noch fertig machen
glücklicherweise waren passanten dabei
die gemeint haben wir müssen unbedingt
polizei und rettung anrufen weil das hat
jetzt nicht so gut ausgeschaut
und ja schlussendlich war sehr sehr gut
also ins krankenhaus mitgefahren bin
hab' dann eben leider diagnose bekommen
dass er einen zweiten lendenwirbel
gebrochen habe und immer für mich war
das im endeffekt wirklich augen öffnen
und man muss einfach sagen es ist
wirklich es ist ein gefährlicher sport
aber sehr schöner sport und es ist es
ist das risiko während meiner meinung
nach und bin natürlich sehr glücklich
dass es nach dreimonatiger
rehabilitation wieder alles perfekt
gelaufen ist und gibt da natürlich zwei
monate lang kosten müssen und schauen
müssen dass so langsam wie möglich
anfangen und somit ist es ja gut
gegangen aber über andere kolleginnen
von mir denn ähnliches gehabt und den
mann noch zu schnell angefangen weil
irgend ein wichtiger wettkampf an
gestanden ist und wenn mal ungeduldig
essen so einer phase dann gehört seit
schlecht aus und dem daraufhin müssen
mit dem sport fährt das vielleicht auch
ein bisschen mit also wenn du jetzt
trainiert und und ausfahrten hass und in
gefahrensituationen kommt dadurch dass
wir schon mal etwas ähnliches erlebt
hast ist das etwas was was man so im
hinterkopf mit behält also die die sache
ist die glaubt dass sie ja oft in den
rückspiegel einfach jetzt automatisiert
ein schau das ist sitzt jetzt person im
auto wenn ihr halt irgendwo knapp an
autos anfahren muss es lässt sie
manchmal nicht vermeiden aber unabhängig
davon würde sagen haben das sehr gut
abgeschlossen
ich weiß das ist ganz wichtig ist da
daran zu arbeiten wenn er direkt an die
unfallstelle hingefahren und habe
eigentlich mit dem thema abgeschlossen
also es hat sich nicht negativ
langfristig beeinflusst oder dass du
jetzt das gefühl dass im rennsituationen
wenn es vielleicht eng hergeht das
fahrradfahren ist ja auch in sich selbst
der sehr gefährlich dass du da sagst
okay das war das haben jetzt so heikel
ich lieber nicht riskiert also ist das
etwas wo man dann auch an diese dinge
denkt würde jetzt nation ist das
ereignis von damals mit spielt also
bestimmt schon definitiv dass der
bahnradsport sehr intensiv und teilweise
sogar aggressiv sein kann
also es wird oft mit früher sogar mit
dem kopf gestoßen worden was natürlich
jetzt von der vom internationalen
verband verband würde aber so mit
ellbogen stöße verteilen das passiert
schon regelmäßig und der man muss sich
halt dann oft entscheidenden gehe jetzt
dieses risiko ein und riskiert sozusagen
mit 99,9 prozentiger sicherheit ein
sturz oder zurück und wert hat im
schlimmsten fall verlieren sozusagen es
dann oft situationen gerade im
zielsprint die man im endeffekt nicht so
beeinflussen kann das an automatisierte
bewegungen und entscheidungen die man
trifft und im nachhinein kann man oft
gar nicht wirklich sagen warum mir in
dem moment entschieden da ein die lücke
rein zu fahren oder nicht
also es kommt glaube von jahrelanger
erfahrung eigentlich also das kann man
auch gar nicht irgendwie bewusst
trainieren dass man sagt man simuliert
bestimmte situationen um dann zu schauen
wie man entscheidet und dann diese
entscheidung vielleicht abzuspeichern
gibt es da mechanismen ja ich glaube
schon dass man im nachhinein im
idealfall mit videoanalyse situationen
anschauen kann und wenn was schlecht
gelaufen ist oder man schlechte
entscheidungen getroffen hat kann man
ich habe das ganz gut in einer anderer
weise visualisieren das heißt dass man
einen mentalen bereich noch viel
herausholt ist definitiv möglich
wie kann man sich dem team ungefähr
vorstellen was braucht das alles damit
du deinen sport erfolgreich ausführen
kannst
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig ist gute
trainingsgruppe drum herum zu haben also
ich bin in wien es momentan wohnhaft und
habe da einige trainings kollegen und
was er ganz wichtig ist dass wir oft
trainingslager gemeinsam machen oder an
das ganze nationalteam zusammenkommt da
es nicht jeder aus dem raum wien und wir
veranstalten hat dann oft trainingslager
auch im süden noch mal locker und da
wird dann wirklich intensiv trainiert
und unabhängig davon ist es natürlich
wichtig ob uns für massagen in anspruch
zu nehmen und zu fuß zu gehen
also es ist ja für jeden medaille
mentaltrainer ist ganz wichtig und dass
man da wirklich auf die regeneration
achtet und nicht nur auf hochintensives
klängen und in diesen trainingsgruppen
dass sie auch mit den herren gemeinsam
gibt es da etwas was man blickt sich
gegenseitig abschauen kann oder es sind
von der technik und und alles im sport
dann die dinge doch eigentlich komplett
gleich sowie das vorher auch
angesprochen hast ja ich komme da
definitiv sehr viel abschauen von den
männern weil wir sehr erfolgreiche
männer aktuellen hamm und ich als
einzige frau habe es natürlich nicht
immer leichte bin dann natürlich auf den
windschatten bei denen aber profitiere
eigentlich von den trainings sehr viel
als wir wenn jetzt nur mit mädels
trainieren würde weil natürlich auch im
rennen die
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeiten immer
höher werden und dementsprechend passte
perfekt mit männern trainieren ich
glaube das ist ein großer vorteil auch
wenn immer wünschen wir dass mehr frauen
auf die bahn kommen
ich glaube dass es sehr wichtig ist dass
sie mit den männern somit trainiert und
was glaubst du können die männer von dir
mitnehmen und lernen aus dem gemeinsamen
trainingseinheiten ich glaube dass die
person bin der am meisten abseits
vielleicht vom radsport macht also ich
schaute zumindest dass sie sehr viel in
der kraft kann man auch was andere
vielleicht nicht so als notwendig
empfinden das war jahrelang eigentlich
die überzeugung dass im radsport das
nicht notwendiges in die kraftkammer zu
gehen dass er ein bisschen anders und
macht dahingehend vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr als also können sie etwas
mitnehmen
du bist wie du dich schon gesagt hast
als einzige international
erfolgreiche bahnen radfahrerinnen ist
natürlich auch ein bisschen ein vorbild
nimmst du dir diese rolle auch irgendwie
bewusst an das du andere für andere
mädchen und andere junge damen vorbild
sein möchte und diese dann auch zu
deinem sport zu bekommen oder ist es
etwas wo du sagst dass das ist jedem
seine sache und und in dieser rolle
möchte ich gar nicht irgendwie gesteckt
werden ja definitiv ich bin gern ein
vorbildung das freut mich jedes mal wenn
man irgendwie merkt dass junge mädels
auf die bahn kommen und man weiß es
nicht immer sicher aber manchmal kann
man sich schon denken dass vielleicht
einer der gründe war dass dass es da
eine frau gibt jedoch internationale
rennen fährt und in zukunft kann ich mir
sehr gut vorstellen irgendwann die
richtung talente coaching oder so zu
gehen und würde sehr gerne meine
erfahrungen weitergeben
ich weiß ich kann selbst aber sehr sehr
viel lernen aber über die jahre hinweg
doch sehr viel mitbekommen wie es
abläuft und dass es nicht immer leicht
ist sich durchzusetzen in einer relativ
männer dominanten welt ist definitiv
klar wenn wir wenn ich manche fehler die
ich begangen habe vielleicht den
weitergeben kann bzw
die vorweg nehmen kann für andere junge
fahrerinnen das würde mich schon freuen
also das sagen hat sich in deiner
karriere am meisten geprägt und und
vielleicht auch verändert für für dein
leben aber auch für seine sportliche
laufbahn
ich glaube einfach dieses das ständige
training und auch wirklich das
durchzuziehen was man sich vorgenommen
hat
also wirklich auch sehr strikt zu sein
und dann am ende doch auch das zuerst
muss man über jahre lang gesagt hat das
ist schon sehr wichtig und es gibt
ständig in einem sportlerleben bergauf
und bergab und ich glaube es kommt immer
ganz darauf an wie man sich auch sehr
anspruchsvollen situationen stellt und
was man daraus macht und ich glaube das
ist so dass das wichtigste ist nicht nur
die die freunde die man macht in dieser
zeit oder die reisen und verschiedenen
kulturen der markt kennen lernt sondern
wirklich hauptsächlich die tatsache dass
man wenn man etwas wirklich will auch
alles erreichen kann man muss auch wenn
man vielleicht nicht die perfekten gene
hat eine perfekte voraussetzungen
ich bin einfach eine person die immer
sehr sehr hart trainiert hat und somit
bin ich eigentlich zu dem punkt kommen
nur jetzt bin und ich bin nach wie vor
bereit sehr sehr hart zu trainieren und
hoffe dass ich nicht auch wenn mich
weiterzuentwickeln ist auch etwas was
erforderlich ist also bei euren umfängen
bei den intensitäten bei den ganzen
sachen die wir machen müssen um ihn in
ordnung sport erfolgreich zu sein wie
leicht tust du dir da auch in den
schweren momenten wirklich dann zu
bleiben ist das etwas ist was dann
wirklich von dir drin dann einfach
weiter geht oder gibt es auch momente wo
dann gesagt mit der motivation ist jetzt
wirklich schwierig da jetzt noch einmal
in die einheit zu gehen die ausfahrt zu
gehen da wirklich die letzten prozente
noch was mir aussuchen wie tust du dir
da also grundsätzlich bisher was nie
wirklich schwierig weil immer große
ziele gesetzt ob und nicht gewusst dass
sie soll damals notwendig auch an
schlechten tagen
das drängen durchzuziehen obwohl man
eigentlich vielleicht gar nicht
motiviert werden oder vielleicht ist man
komplett mühle kontakte vorne aber immer
dann in dem fall das ziel tokio vor
augen gehabt jetzt kurzfristig
mittelfristig setzen wir die europa-
oder weltmeisterschaft medaille als ziel
vor augen und ich glaube so lange weiß
wohin man will dann weiß man auch was es
eigentlich braucht um dahin zu kommen
da kann man halt nicht einfach im
training auslassen das funktioniert
nicht
ja natürlich richtig ohne die arbeit die
man hinein setzte kann das natürlich
nicht wird zu den erfolgen kommen
kannst du dir vorstellen sollte sich zum
beispiel jetzt dass straßen rad fahren
bei den damen weiterentwickeln und und
da große sprünge machen das doch zurück
auf die straße gehst mit seinen
hauptfokus jetzt könnte mir schon
vorstellen ja also jetzt ist ja leider
so dass das wäre sicher stadion
irgendwann in diesem jahr abgerissen
wird und dementsprechend habe natürlich
überlegt werde vielleicht nächstes jahr
wieder mehr auf die straßen gehen dass
das ist definitiv in meinem kopf und
heuer auch schon einen vertrag wieder in
belgien beim belgischen team
das ist aber nach wie vor neben sache
also für mich ist die bahn der
hauptfokus und auf der straße braucht es
natürlich andere sachen dann muss man da
wieder viel viel mehr umfänge trainieren
und auf der bahn in unserer wettkämpfe
seine meistens nur 20 km
maximal und auf der straße sah man
mittlerweile bei 140 km also das wird
anders als bei der umstellung aber ich
sag das jetzt würde die herausforderung
gerne an wenn man also mit den umfängen
hat in dem sinne kein problem
na also aktuell darüber sehr sehr leicht
sehr leicht
es ist mir lieber auf der bahn zu fahren
sage mal aber klappt der körper kann sie
an alles gewöhnen und dementsprechend
steht ich habe ja nichts im wege sich
dann mehr auf die straße zu
konzentrieren
wahlweise ausdauer kann man gut
trainieren schnelligkeit nur zu einem
gewissen grad ja man sieht dass das
studium hat gefruchtet und verwiesen
auch hier bisher dass du anpassungsfähig
warst und das auch weiterhin sein wie
ist alles gute auf jeden fall für deine
zukunft viel gesundheit aufpassen in den
kurven nicht zu schnell fahren
danke dass du heute mit dabei war es
beim sport reporter danke danke auch
dass ihr mit dabei war
wir freuen uns wenn wir beim nächsten
mal wieder beim sport report mit dabei
sein
[Applaus]